stéphane le foll l'un des ministres les
plus proches du chef de l'état françois
hollande est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir soirée merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes en charge de l'agriculture est
aussi au gouvernement du club des
hollandais dit-on ces élus qui ont
partagé un long compagnonnage avec le
chef de l'état au cours de ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l' afp
dailymotion vous serez interrogé tour à
tour tout à l'heure par karim père et
puis perrine tarneaud d'abord entre coup
de rabot du quotient familial et annonce
qu'il faudra travailler plus longtemps
pour partir en retraite parce que le
chef de l'état est condamné aux annonces
et aux réformes douloureuses
on est dans une situation on a trouvé
des déficits partout et en particulier
jusque dans la branche famille deux
milliards et demi ce qui signifie en
fait que on emprunte aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir financer la politique familiale
comme l'a dit le président est réduite
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
accepter ou considérée comme durable ou
soutenable et donc il faut trouver des
solutions et trouver de solution ça
consiste ou à diminuer les prestations
ou à augmenter les recettes et à faire
en sorte qu'on trouve un équilibre
on connaît le choix du chef de l'est de
leur choix était celui du quotient
familial
raboter qui permet de maintenir
l'universalité des allocations
familiales et qui fait qu' on demande
une contribution à ceux qui ont les
revenus les plus élevés
sans remettre en cause cette inertie
normes la gestuelle 1000 euros de plus
par an un port plus de 10% des ménages
or leurs dépens des ménages est au
courant de rien ne dit pas ça comme ça
ça touche 12% lainage 12 % des ménages
qui ont les revenus les plus élevés
c'est un effort qui landais je sais que
c'est toujours difficile d'accepter
l'idée de faire des efforts mais comme
on est dans la situation que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
deux milliards et demi à emprunter ou à
trouver une solution
il faut qu'on le fasse avec l'idée de la
justice on peut faire des économies
plutôt que d'augmenter encore les impôts
je vous rappelle je rappelle ses fans de
folk ignames j'aime bien je
chaque jour vous allez très déçu parce
que ceux qui vous disent ça que ça soit
sur la défense quand on attire le budget
dit ça il faut pas toucher au budget de
défense que ça se soit les allocations
familiales faut pas toucher aux
allocations familiales que ça soit sur
deux le budget de la police ou de la
justice
faut pas toucher au budget ils vous
disent tous qu'il faut faire des
économies mais personne d'état cap est
capable et l'opposition en particulier
de dire où et à chaque fois qu'on en
fait ils sont là pour critiquer donc il
faut être clair et net
oui il faut qu'on fasse des économies
oui on demande des efforts pour
redresser une situation dont on hérite
et qui va bien falloir changer parce que
sinon c'est le modèle lui même qui a mis
en cause il y a quinze jours à peu près
oui le chef de l'état avait dit qu'il
n'augmenterait pas la pression fiscale
sur les français là il ya une
contradiction en un temps record non ya
pas de contradiction
on a dit depuis le départ qu'il
m'apprenne sur les allocations
familiales aux modulations y avait même
dit le chef de l'état par intérim
on ne va pas reprendre d'une main ce
qu'on donne de l'autre c'est absurde
mais exactement et on garde la logique
des allocations familiales et on trouve
une solution pour limiter un déficit qui
je le répète conduit à emprunter pour
assurer cette politique moi je veux bien
a confié à que c'est ça la solution
c'est pas la solution à tout le monde
l'a compris l'hypothèse qui semblait
tenir la corde il ya quelques semaines
encore c'était donc la modulation des
allocations familiales est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire ce soir que françois
hollande a été un petit peu saoul
influence de la manif pour tous et des
manifs porto sus de sa plus pesé dans
son choix ne pas braquer juin qui a été
fait c'est celui qui consiste à se dire
il ya un modèle il a ses atouts ce
modèle il a prouvé d'ailleurs son
efficacité et en même temps il n'est pas
aujourd'hui en situation d'assurer sa
pérennité
2 qu'est ce qu'on fait on garde le
modèle les allocations familiales ça
c'est un choix qui a été fait par la
france qui conduit à une natalité qui
est plus importante en france
qu'ailleurs et qui doit être est ce qui
doit rester
ce modèle est en même temps comme on a
un problème de financement
il faut qu'on essaye de trouver les
solutions justes pour assurer la
pérennité de ce modèle est il vrai que
le savait
à redouter au pire de la manif pour tous
d'ailleurs qui s'est encore manifesté ce
mardi lors de sa venue à marseille
est-ce qu'il a redouté que la situation
du pays lui échappe
non mais entendu dire que la situation
du pays pouvait lui échapper on a
parfaitement mesuré et nuit le premier
ce qui était la mobilisation est ce que
serait d'ailleurs la mobilisation sur un
débat de société où on connaît les
réticences les résistances à certaines
évolutions et à certains progrès qui a
qu'à se rappeler dans l'histoire que ce
soit sur une ivg que ça soit sur le pacs
on est une et débats qui ont toujours
été compliqué donc on savait ça d'accord
pas pour autant qu'on était en train de
se demander et le président de la
république surtout moi j'ai jamais
entendu n'a qu'à leur dire quoi que ce
soit qui consistait à dire sept enfants
nous échappe nacarat qu'avec là alors on
n'a pas parlé des retraites vous avez
posé la question d'emblée également est
ce que là également donc tout le monde
devra contribuer à l'effort l'effort
nécessaire les déficits voulait rappeler
en tous domaines
les actifs et retraités les entreprises
des fonctionnaires c'est manifestement
la recommandation de la commission pour
l'avenir des retraites
là aussi il faut se préparer à des
mesures douloureuses qu'est-ce qui a là
encore sur la table un système de
retraite est essentielle
la répartition c'est ce qui assure la
sécurité pour la retraite et il faut
avoir comme stratégie de préserver cette
idée pour les générations qui commencent
à travailler
j y aura bien une retraite au terme de
leur activité et de leur vie
professionnelle c'est ça l'enjeu
sinon on passe avec un système qui va
être celui de la capitalisation chacun
se fera sa propre retraite
donc il faut qu'on a sur ce socle de
solidarité et c'est pourquoi par rapport
au déficit qui lie à entre ce que sont
les prestations versées pour les
retraités et les cotisations qui sont
prélevés il faut qu'on trouve les moyens
d'équilibrer ce système parce que selon
lui qui est ce qui est important c'est
le système c'est la répartition c'est ça
qui était encore très bien on pourrait
citer d'autres réformes également mais
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui gouverner donc
s'apparente à du masochisme gouverner
dans une situation difficile c'est
difficile par définition si les choses
étaient plus faciles
vous n'auriez pas posé actions comme ça
vous avez découvert l'ampleur des
déficits
on a entendu également le chef de l'état
dire ça je n'ai jamais découvert
l'ampleur de la crise non ce qu'on a dit
c'est que par rapport à ce que nous
savions et on savait que ça serait
difficile et qu'on est dans une crise
c'est vrai que la profondeur de la crise
la preuve c'est tout
les perspectives de croissance ont été
revues à la baisse
que ce soit au niveau européen que ce
soit au niveau de l' ocde
que ce soit au niveau du fmi il y avait
bien donc quelque chose qui s'est passé
qui était encore un peu plus grave que
ce qu'on avait prévu personne n'a nié la
crise toute la campagne
moi je me rappelle même des
commentateurs et des journalistes qui
ont toujours cette tendance et c'est
normal ne regardez que l'instant mais si
on les regarde un peu en arrière
il est à françois hollande il parle de
crise et il n'a pas de grandes
propositions et le grande dépense à
l'époque c'est comment il fait campagne
eh bien on faisait campagne en prenant
en compte la situation connaît tous et
elle est plus grave encore que ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer
eh bien il faut faire face parce que
c'est un pays qu'on a en face de nos
stades peuple c'est une grande nation
il faut qu'on lui offre les perspectives
de l'avenir et du rôle de responsable
s'allonge vous citez vous citez des
grandes organisations économiques
internationales
un hall un site et vous appuyez sur elle
à propos de l'absence de croissance et
le fmi répète aujourd'hui même qu'il
juge difficile d'inverser la courbe du
chômage d'ici la fin de l'année et qui
va même continuer à augmenter en 2014
mais vous vous dites là vous dites pour
tous le conteur je sollicite et où le
fmi craint un qui a salué les réformes
qui est engagée oui n'oubliez de le dire
d'accord c'est normal mais bien sûr mais
à ses côtés ce thé je suis pas vous news
le fait mort départ démordra pas non le
président a admis qu'elle fixe un regard
désespéré pays on a comme objectif
d'inverser cette cour eh bien on se met
en ordre de bataille pour inverser la
courbe est finalement quoi qu'on veut
quand 10 à paris c'est bien le programme
la commission européenne qui se met en
place
c'est le programme et le projet du
président de la république tel qu'il a
exprimée pendant la campagne
si je prends les retraites alors là vous
pouvez regarder toutes les classes
emmènerait dans la durée de cotisation
depuis des pas et même au moment des
primaires
shine est il ya eu là dessus de volonté
de masquer ou de refuser de dire surtout
de son opposition à la réforme sarkozy
1 on se souvient de l'opposition à la
réforme sarkozy qui a toujours été
étayées d'ailleurs de la même manière
que l'opposition je m'en souviens très
bien en 2003 la réforme de raffarin
sous chirac toujours été la même de même
la même analyse
il y avait une manière de traiter cette
réforme qui consistait à le prendre sur
un angle uniquement comptable et à ne
pas tenir compte de ce que nous
revendiquons aujourd'hui c'est 'qui il
faudra régler problème des retraites est
la pérennité du système
en étant dans une stratégie de justice a
fait lire toujours ça comme pour les
allocations familiales rigas donc au
bout du compte on paye plus pour la
politique familiale est plus grave est
que longtemps après en gagnant moi même
au bout d'un conte fission oui on est
dans une logique d'efforts qui est
demandé et en même temps qui est fait
avec le souci de la justice
mais oui c'est ça et ça a été dit et
répété pendant toute la campagne va pas
changer maintenant est ce que c'est la
marque
je vous interroger sur la commission de
bruxelles à surveiller de très près qui
les réclament les réformes structurelles
engagées ou espérer en france stéphane
le foll ce que vous partager
l'indignation du président socialiste de
l'assemblée nationale claude bartolone
pour qui la commission européenne
représente un déni de démocratie elle
est contre le suffrage universel dit il
et l'alimentent partie des injonctions
le rejet de l'europe
moi je ne dirais pas ça je dirais
simplement que la commission un rôle qui
est de faire respecter des traités qui
ont été signés par des états qui ont été
élus eux par des gouvernements et des
chefs d'états de manière démocratique et
qu'elle doit s'en tenir à cela et que
c'est vrai que dans l'expression qui
était celle du président de la
commission
on a eu droit à
espèce de discours de politique générale
qui n'avait pas à être fait par le
président de la commission la france est
souveraine
la france a décidé la france a choisi
elle respectera ses engagements et en
même temps on n'est pas là pour dire à
la france voilà ce qu'il faut faire
même si dans les faits c'est la même
chose mais dans les zones des calques
notaires les taxis aux fins jeudi le
président de la commission est allée
dans le détail car libéré à la demande
face à la commission européenne tient je
vous donne l'occasion de la féliciter
peut-être aujourd'hui puisqu'elle engage
un bras de fer avec la chine
en instaurant des taxes temporaires sur
les panneaux solaires voilà vous saluer
cette initiative est ce que c'est la
victoire également de la france sur
l'allemagne qui avait dit non
c'est en tout cas la prise de conscience
que l'europe telle qu'elle s'est
construite en termes d libre échange et
d'accès aux marchés européens
jusqu'ici sans aucune demande de
contrepartie commencent à prendre
conscience qu'on a besoin dans les
changes nécessaire parce que l'europe
est le premier exportateur
il faut toujours penser que lorsqu'on
s'engage à dire à quelqu'un ça va pas on
va fermer
eh bien il ya aussi le risque que
lui-même et des rétentions donc on est
bien dans un choix stratégique qui
consiste à dire oui aux échanges mais
pas à n'importe quelle condition et
surtout que les conditions soient
équitables elles ne le sont pas en
particulier sur la question des panneaux
solaires
il y a une réponse qui graduée qui
tentait de vendre pour la commission de
la commission fait là un travail qui le
quine pour lançant de grands choix de
brammo sur la chine avant d'aller plus
loin dans les questions politiques
est ce que ça vous inquiète tous ces
investissements chinois notamment en
france dans le domaine de l'alimentaire
ou du vin on avec un groupe chinois
avait racheté par exemple moi ce que
j'ai constaté la gelée en chine célèbre
docteur de saucisson les marques les
plus connues
moi quand je suis allé en chine ce que
j'ai constaté d'abord c'est que la
france au travers des vins en
particulier est le premier exportateur
ou
producteur ou vendeurs de 20,1 chine il
ya un intérêt des chinois pour
l'histoire et la culture écossaise et à
pratiquer sur le vin dont il faut qu'on
soit capable aussi d'être à la hauteur
ils on avait dit qu'il fallait ouvrir
j'ai dit non peut pas non plus dire je
me ferme non puisque nous mêmes nous
voulons que les chinois s'ouvre quand
j'ai rencontré le fils quand je rentrais
je le vice premier ministre chinois
moi j'ai négocié on a négocié ensemble
sur des protocoles pour ouvrir le marché
en particulier sur la question du cochon
et d'autres questions est bon sur les
questions sanitaires et en même temps
mais eux aussi ils ont un intérêt et la
france ya intérêt d'avoir des
investisseurs qui parient sur la france
bon voilà la chine ont fait partie il ya
comme celle d'ailleurs oui mais bien sûr
il ya un sujet qui donne lieu à une
reculade difficile de le nier c'est la
fameuse moralisation de la vie politique
annoncée par françois hollande on s'en
souvient pour se sortir de la sphère
cahuzac et si cette grande réforme de la
transparence était en train de faire
pschitt avant d'accueillir karine
perrelle afp qui a beaucoup de questions
à poser sans révéler a toujours beaucoup
de titres ont fait le point avec
mathilde de bélanger sur cette nouvelle
question polémique qui revient à la une
les règles qui régissent l'établissement
le contrôle et la publication des
patrimoines des responsables publics
seront entièrement revu c'était début
avril dans le sillage de la sphère
cahuzac françois hollande promettait la
transparence sur les patrimoines des
ministres et les parlementaires
finalement la montagne devrait accoucher
d'une souris les élus devront bien
remplir une déclaration de patrimoine
qui sera consultable en préfecture mais
elle ne pourra pas être diffusé une
reculade pour l'opposition et pour les
écologistes qui était très favorable au
texte bien urgence le président la
république annonce rapidement des
mesures fortes
deux semaines plus tard c'est déjà
détricotées et au bout de six semaines
il ne reste plus rien donc on voit un
petit peu comment les socialistes
gouvernent ce pays et je veux dit
lamentable je suis constamment soit on
dit il n'ya pas de publication et un
meilleur contrôle soit dia publication
mais ce côté on fait les choses au quart
du tiers de la moitié on comprend même
pas ce que ça veut dire mais pour la
plupart des parlementaires le compromis
est une victoire
à droite comme à gauche presque tous les
élus s'étaient opposés à la publication
de leur patrimoine
au premier rang d'entre eux le président
de l'assemblée claude bartolone qui
avait mis en garde contre une démocratie
paparazzi les engagements du président
de la république vont être concrétisés
il avait indiqué qu'il souhaitait que le
patrimoine des élus soient publiés il va
l'être
simplement il ne va pas être ouverts à
tous vents
il ya tout à la fois le souci du
contrôle la publication la vérification
et pour la possibilité pour tout citoyen
comme pour les impôts d'ailleurs de
consulter pour contrôler ces
déclarations le projet de loi prévoit la
création d'une haute autorité de la
transparence qui pourra procéder à des
vérifications auprès de l'administration
fiscale
le texte sera débattu à l'assemblée
entre le 17 et le 19 juin jean vincent
placé parle d'une un projet de loi
finalement lamentable je le cite donc
finalement ce ne sont que des
propositions au rabais non ça a été dit
par les gènes de s'exprimer il ya dans
ce débat l'accord qui a été trouvé mais
le parlement sur ce sujet c'est lui qui
vote la loi
donc quand je vois l'opposition d'hier
on n'est pas allé assez loin
faut-il que l'opposition sont d'accord
pour aller le plus loin possible et
écolo alors les écologistes je veux pas
faire de commentaires sur ce qu'a dit
jean vincent placé
moi je fais des commentaires sur les
faits qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
le fait que les déclarations qui sont
faites aujourd'hui zidi sts son
dirigés vers une autorité qui les
contrôle plus ou moins et ne sont pas
plus quand même j'espère plus que moins
si vous voulez elles ne sont pas
publiées aujourd'hui tout citoyen pourra
consulter le patrimoine de tous les élus
ce qui a été évité ce qu'ils
souhaitaient éviter
d'après ce que je comprends de la part
des parlementaires c'est le côté que
nous avons prévu connu dans la manif
fait d'aller voilà pour dire nous nous
sommes d'accord pour dire ah il faut
moraliser
il faut de la transparence et il faut
pouvoir contrôler ce que sont les
déclarations donc cette haute autorité a
la possibilité de contrôler et n'a
apporté un plat câble je suis ému et
implacable elle est implacable dans la
mesure où on perd mais sur la base d'une
déclaration de faire toutes les
vérifications et on permet à un citoyen
d'aller voir s'il a quelque chose qui
lui semble peut-être pas tout à fait
clair il pourra vérifier pourra saisir
la haute autorité consultables mais non
publiables les centristes si on ne
voulait pas réagir aux propos des
écologistes qui sont très virulents
effectivement je me sens pas céder oui
j'en attends des gens voulaient fait un
sort particulier chez les jeunes
oui il faut s'activer mais qu'est ce
qu'a dit françois de rugy il a dit je le
cite qui comprendrait qu'une loi sur la
transparence finissent par le secret et
l'opacité
bon cela il faut discuter est-ce qu'il
ya secret et s'il ya ou pas citer parce
que c'est vrai ça c'est ça situe un
jugement est le fait que les métiers il
ya plus de métier aucun métier
internationale je n'ai pas là dessus de
de position définitive parce que je ne
crois pas que la position soit 10
filiales consensus n'ai pas
d'information précise sur le sujet sur
quel consensus il ya on est dans la
commission des lois où on est en
discussion qui a eu lieu
moi pour l'instant ce que je constate à
l'objectif qui est de dire il faut
confondant capacité de savoir ce qu'est
le patrimoine pour éviter ce qu'il ya
déjà eu lieu et de vérifier
il ya bien une haute autorité il ya bien
la possibilité de consulter
il ya bien la possibilité de vérifier et
de l'abus site et d'engager pour
et ça ça participera à la moralisation
de la vie publique
on est en retrait quand même par rapport
à ce que rappelait carey les grandes
intentions martiale du chef de l'état
elles ont été mises en application pour
ce qui est du gouvernement là nous
sommes vis-à-vis de l'assemblée sur
l'ensemble des élus il faut qu'on tienne
compte de ce que les élus expriment mais
en même temps la ligne qui avaient été
définis par le président de la
république se retrouvent concrétiser
vous en tant que ministre vous avez payé
le prix fort alors vous avez vous dû
déclarer vos deux maisons votre
motoneige qui y ont des effets plus
forts
oui il sauf que je vais me laisser
quelqu'un crever il a déclaré elle est
gelée perdu en cours de route juste à la
fin de l'année précédente donc moi je
priais prix fort juge je considère que
j'ai rien à cacher je dirigeais pas moi
mon histoire les elle est claire elle
est transparente qu'est ce que je vais
faire
hirano surtout ne jouais pas qu'on sache
que j'ai une maison roman est une autre
raison au mans avec ça j'ai tout le
monde le sait j'ai une moto si j'avais
pas d'ailleurs j'ai failli l'oublier
donc c'est pour ça que je dis rajouter
mais il avait passé tous et que j'ai une
moto je viens de l'eau mais là j'ai pas
d'égarer vélo bon d'accord moi je ne
suis même pas posé la question ça m'a
pas stresser les bombes est d'accord
alors vous dites vous n'avez rien à
cacher vous êtes un proche de françois
hollande vous êtes un ministre dit
hollandais vous appartenez à ce plan
hollande est aussi semaine il ya plus
que depuis il ya puis secrétaire
d'arbitrage une discussion satisfait que
ministre bis n'ont pas concédé les cinq
ans et demis on discute des projets de
loi ou des communications sur des futurs
projets de loi là on discute entre
personnes politiques qui se chauffent
les sujets d'inventaire le preuve de
préjugés ça me paraît normal qu'il ait
discussion
elle est franche elle est claire et
transparente ça permet d'assurer une
cohérence je pense que tout le monde le
coup le disait où sont les convergences
entre le gouvernement le parti avait
besoin de ce lieu il est là et il est
très utile alors de quoi on cause des
sujets politiques
c'est les bonnes relations que vous avez
retenu de la réunion de lundi là par
exemple aujourd'hui sur le quotient
familial sur les retraites tout ça c'est
de saison tout est calé la pac elle est
là parce que les décisions la commère
été annoncées juste avant oui mais on
discute mais sert mal la politique c'est
tout un art qui consiste aussi à la fois
à penser à exprimer des conditions à les
traduire et à défendre ses positions
donc voilà et ça nécessite de la
discussion
je crois que le pire c'est de s'enfermer
1 et de faire comme certains ça a été vu
il ya quelques temps à la présidence de
la république on s'enferme on décide
tout tout seul ça marche pas 1 vous
collègue manuel valls dit qu'il serait
prêt à assumer ses responsabilités
nouvelles habilités s'il si on
l'appelait pour matignon
je vais qu'est ce que vous en pensez on
connait la vôtre exactitude et votre
précision si il se trouverait qu'on
l'appelait bon ben voilà il a tout dit
ici qui décide c'est le président de la
république pour l'instant aujourd'hui il
ya eu clairement voilà y'a gouvernement
et continue il dit qu il le jure il le
jour viendra quand il le décidera
et si à ce moment-là ya une proposition
j'imagine que sont la main de le bassin
analysera et répondre dans dix ans il
pourrait être le candidat naturel mais
si vous vous rendez compte que vous
mettez un poisson si j'étais lui l'a
fait
selon hubert sait ce qu'il veut
moi je ne ferai pas de prospective
je ne suis pas là pour en faire imaginez
un peu si j'avais été là en 2009
en vous disant je vais soutenir françois
hollande jusqu'au bout et vous verrez il
sera président de la nuit que vous
m'auriez dit stéphane le foll des signes
on est un peu bizarre parce que je suis
et elle a remis un peu sèchement à sa
place dans cette interview à la provence
je ne crois pas ah non là dessus avant
simple et clair qui décide
le président de la république un
remaniement un gouvernement très présent
vers un public qui décide
il a dit récemment qu'il y avait qu'une
seule ligne politique au gouvernement de
son accord bien entendu oui arnaud
montebourg a dit il ya deux patrons à
bercy c'est une tradition là ça n'a pas
été calé la réunion de lundi à matignon
mais c'est lorsqu'il ya deux patrons
qu'il a dit il y avait deux lignes
justement il a dit qu'avec une seule
mais c'était ça qui est important
nkm qui a été élu largement oui
candidate pour les municipales de 2014
c'est une candidate redoutable
moi je suis à une crème candidate à
longjumeau mater faire de la politique
on beaulieu et non je bouge qu'on
appelle parce que l'ange humour histoire
socialiste que je connais bien et elle
avait dit à ce moment-là je ne quitterai
jamais longe humour c'était en 2008
nous sommes en 2013 elle a quitté
longjumeau et deuxièmement je me
souviens aussi il n'ya pas si longtemps
pensé que le ticket de métro était à 4
euros
donc il faut que sur paris elle fasse
beaucoup de progrès pour s'imprégner de
ce qu'est cette ville capitale
et donc ces mets tout adversaire
politique doit être respectée mais je
note quand même que ya pas si longtemps
nathalie kosciusko morizet était à
l'enjeu est toujours député de mon jeu
doté de l'ump qui lui a donné sa
divinité mais ça n'empêche pas que je
puisse dire qu'il n'ya pas si longtemps
c'était pas paris qui n'intéressaient
donc cette découverte soudaine d'un
intérêt pour eux sur paris fera le
prouver et je rappelle qu'il n'ya pas si
longtemps elle disait que le ticket de
métro et à 4,9 la baguette état
un petit peu plus d'un euro ça dépendra
5 centimes ça dépend c'est une tradition
chez moi que les courses
voilà voilà m mais mais nous nous sommes
candidat à rien et aucune fonction était
bien sûr présente et jazzy également qui
dit il finalement il pourrait revenir en
politique qu'il est prêt il le dit hier
à londres
qu'est ce que vous en pensez le joug
l'homme providentiel en quelque sorte
mais il peut jouer le rôle qu'il veut il
était président de la république il a
été battu non pas que nancy il a des
ambitions il le dira moi je veux pas
faire de commentaires sur ce sujet je
rappelle simplement qu'on est encore
loin et que à droite
il y aura aussi un débat et que la
droite est profondément divisée
aujourd'hui entre des lignes politiques
qui sont incarnés soit par deux
subissions d'ailleurs qui a fait un
commentaire très désagréable sur madame
kosciusko morizet qui était la ligne de
nicolas sarkozy point la présidentielle
puis une autre ligne du traditionnel de
la droite qui s'exprime aujourd'hui
après la défaite de la présidentielle
donc tant que cette question là n'est
pas réglé on doit toujours avoir des
candidats je crois pas que ce soit si
simple à régler nos mois nicolas sarkozy
fera ce qu'il voudra mais quand il dit
il le dit d'ailleurs en marge op en dans
une conférence rémunéré à londres qu'il
reviendrait cher d'ailleurs par de voir
si on l'appelle que vous pensez de cette
posture d'un ancien chef de l'état qui
sont je pense que c'est bien compliqué
par de voir si on m'appelle qu'il
appelle fallu poser la question des
sondages
on verra donc moi vous savez sur tout ça
je connais la politique assez bien et
quand on est loin d'une échéance tous se
passer plein de choses mais d'ici là il
va se passer plein de choses jean
françois copé le président l'ump qui dit
un dîner privé que finalement il est
pour le mariage
je veux ça et qui qui passons qui a
passé son temps à défiler dans la rue
qu'est ce que moi je pense que le vrai
problème en politique aujourd'hui c'est
que pour certains c'est la sincérité
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
moi j'ai un peu plus de 50 ans j'ai vécu
cinquante ans à la 4e circonscription
jamais bougé
jamais jamais bougé j'ai pas 7
conception de la politique deuxièmement
je me dis qu'en politique on a besoin de
sincérité et j'aime pas ceux qui
trichent
alors ça peut être difficile par moments
on voit bien quand il ya des débats ça
peut être difficile mais on doit faire
l'effort de la sincérité il n'y a rien
de plus désagréable dans la politique
que ceux qui cherchent à cacher quelque
chose à tricher pour pouvoir séduire un
moment il faut rester clair transparent
et sincère je trouve que le fait de
prendre
monsieur copé à jour par défaut alors
qu'il a été sur toutes les
manifestations pour dire tout le mal
qu'ils pensaient c'est pas bien c'est
quelqu'un qui n'assument pas ceux qui ne
pensent ça c'est pas bien vous dites il
peut se passer beaucoup de choses
jusqu'à 2017 est on en train d'accord là
dessus il ya eu un petit rebond de
françois hollande dans les sondages de
quelques points pour penser qu'il peut
renverser la tendance vous êtes très
affirmatif sur le chômage est ce que
vous l'êtes également moi je suis
l'arrivée de surprise en battant le
chômage est ce que vous êtes sur les
sondages moi je ne fais pas de paris sur
les sondages et donc j'ai je le jure je
mesure à la fois à chaque fois qu'il se
lâche ou mauvais et quand il se redresse
je suis satisfait mais je ne ferai aucun
pari je sais que la réussite de france
au volant et donc son niveau dans les
sondages les rendra de la réussite du
pays tout entier peut donner pour
réussir deux dernières questions qui
concernent la majorité des élections
partielles
on va avoir lieu ce week-end et en juin
donc la circonscription de l'étranger
amérique du nord et puis dans la
circonscription pardon de jérôme cahuzac
le ps va perdre certainement peut perdre
c
peux t qui est en train d'être rogné
petit à petit et bien sûr je veux qu'on
perd des partiels ça diminue long de
député on a encore un peu de marge mais
c'est vrai que ça devient un sujet et en
même temps cette bataille des partiels
on le sait toutes partiel poste victoire
électorale il ya plus dynamique
il ya une faible participation et ça ne
bénéficient que très rarement au pouvoir
en place merci car ils paieraient
d'avoir été avec nous cette semaine
alors on dit les français maussade que
dire des agriculteurs dont le moral
comme les cultures bien sûr est atteint
en ce moment par le printemps pourri
avant d'accueillir perrine tarneaud de
public sénat pour les questions qui
relèvent de votre compétence ministériel
stéphane le foll ont le reportage de
mounir souci parmi les sinistrés
professionnels de la météo donc en
seine-et-marne des mouettes qui prennent
leurs quartiers dans un champ de
céréales l'image pourrait prêter à
sourire si les dégâts sur les
plantations n'était pas désastreux vous
voyez là on a des plans qui sont
complètement on a l'impression qu'on est
en train de repartir mais ils sont ils
sont foutus suis là c'est pareil ils
sont ils sont c'est quand même trois
mois
on n'y arrivera pas le sol porte les
stigmates de la mauvaise météo du mois
de mai la crue a noyé le tiers de cette
exploitation
implantée en zone inondable cet
agriculteur est habitué à voir la scène
recouvrir ses champs mais pas à cette
saison on est vraiment dans des
situations exceptionnelles
la situation empirait je voulais lycée
la date et la date on peut plus rien
faire derrière on attend will des
pouvoirs publics qui nous qui nous aide
à passer ce cap on a décru tardive de
printemps bras j'en ai pris une en 2001
et j'ai mis 5 6 ans à m'en remettre
ce producteur de seine et marne ne peut
faire une croix sur ces parcelles gorgée
d'eau où les cultures semées vont
pourrir les pommes de terre céréales ou
oignons cultivé et submergé ne pourront
pas être récoltés ce qui se traduit par
une perte sèche de revenus moi j'estime
la perte à peu près cent mille euros
donc ça veut dire un résultat nul voire
négatif cette année et j'ai des
programmes et mes investissements pour
l'année prochaine pour absorber le choc
cet exploitant aura besoin de souplesse
dans sa trésorerie
c'est une des revendications du
principal syndicat agricole la fnsea
appelle à la solidarité des pouvoirs
publics et réclament des aides directes
versées aux agriculteurs touchés car ils
ont joué le rôle de tampon pour empêcher
les crues dans les zones urbaines on a
évité que des villes comme paris chalon
dijon sévilla n'ont pas été inondées
parce qu'il ya eu des barrages on a
retenu l'eau sur les terres agricoles
maintenant contrepartie nous souhaitons
que l'état renvoie par un soutien
financier auprès des agriculteurs qui
ont leurs activités économiques est
remise en cause les opérations de
chiffrage des dégâts sont en cours les
premiers dédommagements ne devrait pas
intervenir avant l'automne
voilà perrine tarneaud est avec nous
bonsoir perrine vos mines et vos
questions aux ministres de l'agriculture
le falher justement sur cette question
des intempéries est ce que vous avez
déjà une idée des pertes subies par les
agriculteurs
d'abord pour arriver à évaluer les
pertes il faut qu'il y ait une décrue on
imagine à peu près puisque on a quand
même les surfaces timité savoir
exactement ce qui est venu sous ce que
c'était des prix est ce que c'était des
cultures moi j'ai déjà dit il ya
jours on a un plan qu'on mettra en
oeuvre pour chaque département qui a été
touchée après des évaluations qui sont
en fait c'est vrai que ça va prendre un
peu de temps à chaque fois c'est comme
ça mais c'est l'argent des lisation
avant l'automne mais bien sûr que c'est
on peut pas indemniser sans évaluer je
vais un mois de l'argent public c'est
suffisamment voilà en tout talent disais
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire comme
économie est bien là il faut quand même
que je sois capable et on va mobiliser
tout de suite tous les outils qui sont
nécessaires à la fois sur les
cotisations sur les reports sur un
certain nombre d'annuités sur les
possibilités qui seront verts d'utiliser
jachères pour faire du fourrage
on a mis en place un dispositif on va
évaluer on va regarder bien sûr on est
mobilisé bien sûr que la solidarité
je voudrais juste dire par rapport à ce
que dit monsieur nous faisons attention
à dire en gros on a protégé les villes
en noyant les oui c'est ça je crois que
j'ai connu ça moi j'ai été inondé sauf
comment j'ai été inondée en 95 je sais
parfaitement et le côté cédé autres
qu'il faut les encres n est non il faut
qu'on soit beaucoup plus dans jules idée
simple oui il faudra que la solidarité
s'exprime et elle s'exprimera et l'etat
sera là pour venir en aide aux
agriculteurs mais ce que vous pouvez
dire ce soir qu'on va vers quand même
une année dramatique pour les
producteurs de fruits et légumes de
fleurs en france
dramatiser pas comme ça elise de même
ils sont obligés eux ils vont être
obligés d'importer pour revendre mais
déjà l'an dernier avec les gels vous
avez oubliez ça l'an dernier déjà il ya
eu une perte en termes de production qui
a fait que les prix d'ailleurs se sont
maintenus là aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on a un retard sur la mise en
végétation en production et avec sur 7
un fruit des vrais problèmes
donc là aussi il ya l'aléa climatique il
existe et donc mon objectif d'ailleurs
sur cette question sasac dans la réforme
de la politique agricole est dans ce
qu'on mettra en place
j'ai la prise en compte de cette
dimension pas nouvelle parce que l'a
toujours été
elle a toujours existé l'agriculture et
face à la nature mais en maintenant il
faut qu'on soit capable d'avoir des
outils encore plus face pour pouvoir
traiter ces questions mais seuls 30% des
agriculteurs sont stationnés en moyenne
dans certains à partir du moment où ces
aléas climatiques se multiplient c'est
absolument raison c'est que l'assurance
privée ces deux-là ginter lui-même ne
peut pas comprendre
c'est là où les préjudices qu'ils sont
liés à des gros aléas climatiques sépare
est donc il faut qu'on assure il faut
qu'on fasse un système collectif
je pense que là dessus il ya aussi à
mobiliser une partie petites parties
mais il faudra qu'on en discute des
éléments du budget européen
alors justement on parle du budget
européen ne parle pas le parlement
européen a durci le ton à l'égard des
états membres aujourd'hui il trouve que
l'accord sur la future pac être m
est-ce que c'est au parlement européen
de poser de tels duty matin c'est au
parlement au conseil et la commission
des trilogues d'avancé pour trouver des
solutions et je ne crois pas que c'est
en se renvoyant la balle pour dire y'en
a qui va pas assez vite qu'on va y
arriver donc moi je suis là et je les
dis d'ailleurs au conseil informel à
dublin
attention on a tous une responsabilité
autour de la table il y avait le
parlement il y avait l'ensemble des
ministres de l'agriculture il y avait la
commission on a tous une responsabilité
et cette responsabilité dans le trilogue
c'est de faire en sorte que entre les
points qui sont ceux du parlement
européen ceux qui ont été adoptées par
le conseil des ministres et
éventuellement la position de la
commission
là où il ya convergence ont fait accord
rapidement et là où il ya des points de
divergence on les traite avec un
objectif rapprocher les points de vue
avec rapprocher les points de vue le
parlement européen qui veut aussi
visiblement remettre sur la table de
négociation des points déjà conclu
dernier conseil européen notamment sur
le plafonnement des subventions des
agriculteurs là il ya une inde et baky
qui est historique
au niveau de la politique agricole
commune je connais ce débat par coeur
depuis toutes les réformes macciarini
déjà plafonnement même madame fischer
boel était libéral plafonnement et il ya
des états il ya des états pour des
raisons historiques avec l'allemagne sur
les anciens le système collectif et dans
des grandes exploitations où le sud de
l'espagne
historiquement très extensive qui
refuseront le plafonnement parce que
pour le coup c'est pénaliser une
histoire agricole qui n'est pas la nôtre
qui n'est pas celle d'autres pays donc
je connais ça par coeur il faut que là
aussi on sera capable moi j'ai proposé
depuis le départ en tout cas la
dégressivité des aides
la france a fait une proposition c'est
le paiement redistributif
on change de sujet puisqu'on apprend
aujourd'hui la fermeture en bretagne de
deux sites de marine harvest c'est le
leader mondial du saumon c'est une
entreprise suédoise 450 postes sont
menacés que peut faire le gouvernement
mais là d'abord cette dépêche est sorti
cet après midi je connais un peu too
loud
oui ouistes france oui mais je vous le
dis moi j'ai pas été saisi il ya
quelques jours avant de cette hypothèse
comme à chaque fois le choix qui est
fait pour des raisons économiques dans
cette entreprise que je connais pas mais
donc je vois les sites en particulier à
poullaouen effet ou annoncés et donc
l'état va être obligé et sera là pour
essayer d'abord de trouver des solutions
des solutions de réindustrialisation des
solutions pour les salariés
on peut pas laisser à la à la bande aux
emplois j'ai sur le mât table depuis que
je suis arrivé la question de doux que
je continue j'ai eu une rencontre hier
pour trouver des solutions pour essayer
d'avancer pour éviter le maximum de
licenciement j'ai la question de gad et
de la production porcine
et puis je viens d'apprendre sur cette
question du chômage donc à chaque fois
l'etat sera là on fera tout ce qui est
en dedans moi pour aider et éviter les
catastrophes sur c'est à dire séduire
notamment sur le dossier double décennie
m vous êtes lambert est la renommant
jour de l'agriculture avec guillaume
garot au travail sur l'agroalimentaire
sur d'où on a du mal mais on peut pas
dire non plus qu'on ait laissé tomber et
que depuis il ya une pérennisation et on
va continuer et je ferai tout pour
assurer le maintien de cet acquis alors
c'est lui qui vous appelle aussi à
l'aide
aujourd'hui c'est laurent spanghero il
dépose demain une offre de reprise de la
société qui porte son nom mais qui
appartient au groupe et lui remet à zéro
c'est effectivement le scandale de la
viande de cheval alors lui des plans ne
pas être assez soutenue par les pouvoirs
publics pour sauver les 240 emplois en
jeu est ce que vous êtes prêts à l'aider
mais là encore je ne peux pas accepter
l'idée que on renvoie sur les pouvoirs
publics d'abord une responsabilité je le
rappelle
oui oui d'accord
nous on n'est pas lui le patron
c'était pas lui le patron c'est lui qui
a vendu lui il veut racheter sauver les
envies avait racheté avec eux quel moyen
d'accord il faut qu'on regarde et ça
sera l'objet de la proposition
nous on est là pour aider j'ai encore vu
guillaume garot avant son départ au
japon et nous travaillons pour essayer
de voir comment sur la question de
l'abattoir sur la question des plats
transformé sur la question liée à la
conserverie on peut trouver des
solutions robustes aussi je veux pas
raconter d'histoires c'est pas
simplement on va reprendre aujourd'hui
moi je les ai vus au niveau des grands
distributeurs de ceux qui peuvent
acheter des produits
il n'y a pas de confiance personne ne
veut faire donc il faut qu'on redonne
cette confiance et si nous ne l'avions
pas fait ce que nous avons fait et si la
direction n'avait pas aussi était si
l'on n'y a toujours pas eu une décision
de prise
il s'est quand même passé des choses qui
n'étaient pas claires donc on remet tout
ça en ordre
donc il faut pas être là non plus en
disant je vais pas le soutien de leurs
noms mais temps mais bien sûr ils sont
guère à l'état qui a la responsabilité
devant tous les consommateurs de ce qui
s'est passé vous rappeler si vous
m'aviez invités le jour où on avait
découvert qu'à la place du boeuf
il y avait du cheval qu'est ce qu'on
nous a dit alors qu'est ce que fait
l'état
ah bah si j'avais été là en train de
manger fait et nous avons fait avec
benoît - guillaume garot ce que nous
devions faire mais en même temps nous
laisserons pas tomber des singles et
nous lâchons nous n'avons jamais fait et
là encore on sera là pour essayer de
trouver des solutions et la
responsabilité n'est pas celle de l'état
ça je tiens à le dire aujourd'hui de
manière claire et ferme sur ces
scandales alimentaires
justement benoît enquêter sur ce plateau
à votre place il ya deux semaines nous
disaient qu'il y à d'autres scandales
qui vont arriver est ce que vous
confirmez ses propos mais je ne confirme
pas parce que moi je ne fais pas
d'anticipation sur ce genre de sujet on
a déjà ces scandales à traiter je suis
assez furieux d'ailleurs chaque fois que
je vois mais quand je vois que des
opérateurs se permette de tricher je je
il ya eu là encore quelque chose sûre
c'était sur une production sur la
volaille les oeufs
c'est insupportable qu'est ce que fait
l'homme politique qui ministre
aujourd'hui quand on dévoile votre pied
des fonds surtout une idée de
l'agriculture française de
l'agroalimentaire français où on défend
une image qui est la nôtre je peux pas
accepter c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
dans la loi de benoît hamon les
sanctions qui seront prises
est ce que devront payer ceux qui
trichent ça va être multiplié par trois
ou quatre
tant mieux il a raison c'est
insupportable merci des moyens pour
contrôler j'avais les moyens largement
alors on n'essaye pas lui donner aux
entreprises elles mêmes
là encore faire des économies d'accord
et qu'est ce que vous me dites
et ben moi j'ai fait des choix et sur la
question des contrôles justement ça fait
partie des priorités
alors vous avez signé un instant
répondant à perrine concernant les
assurances contre les aléas climatiques
qui avaient peut-être de l'argent à
trouver dans la pac
ouais ben justement on a été très frappé
un perrine cette semaine par la
découverte
on a vu avec surprise que la pac n'était
pas que les acteurs du nord notamment
dans votre département mais aussi un
golf un aéroport des cantines scolaires
des centres
tout ça au nom de projets de
développement dites moi une cantine
alors peut-être pour le bio mais enfin
il ya aussi des centres culturels mais
c'est vrai dans tous les départements
partout sur les actes sur alors excuse
un détournement d'argent oui le débat
aujourd'hui dans la le débat qu'on a
c'est de clarifier ce qu'on appelle les
actifs agricoles et si on doit donner un
budget à la politique agricole c'est
pour défendre l'agriculture a des
qualités spécifiques de 2e pilier de la
politique agricole
c'est de faire du développement rural
vraiment pas se tromper on en a besoin
aussi si vous annoncez là comme ça alors
marc hecker a donné deux défunts des
détournements il ya des chants des golfs
n'essaie pas propre ici à la france
partout en europe on discute et on va
clarifier c'est ce qu'on appelle l'
actif agricole a essayé de cibler les
faire des listes pour que on donne des
aides aux aliments arrestation si les
golfs donc relève des actifs agricoles
donc le débat non est lancée et vous
répondez non à cette question stéphane
le foll merci ainsi d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci perrine à la tous
très vite